just to see how the patient how's the
patient in a resourceful there are two
types of patients now at Warrington
Hospital covert and non-coated
and they go to strenuous lengths to
ensure they don't mix the emergency
department is now in two halves and this
is a red zone where the latest arrival
is a man with coronavirus symptoms the
hospital's covert cots are called their
security guards used to patrolling the
grounds now trusted with keeping
patients safe and the virus at bay they
close corridors and sealed doorways to
[Music]
secure a route to take the patient up to
a coronavirus ward as quickly as
possible
how do your family feel about you doing
it the trauma teams are coping with the
life of which they've never seen before
this is a simulation their training on
the job in the middle of a pandemic it's
crucial they work out how to stay ahead
of this deadly virus that few in the
world know much about
this is coping with emergencies in the
time of coronavirus everyone could be a
potential covert patient and not long
into this training session the team
realized the life-saving treatment they
have to do means they're putting
themselves in danger
[Music]
most of them aren't wearing enough
personal protective equipment so they
have to leave the simulated emergency to
kit up many are from different
departments working together for the
first time and there are constant they
need to keep thinking of new tactics to
tackle this virus donors like a woman
reborn since we last met look how she
was just days earlier now she's living
every second and loving every minute and
I'm feeling so much better I'm so much
happier you know I'm getting there and
he smells coming back my taste is coming
back she didn't think she'd make it I
was so scared I just thought
oh my god because they looked after me
so well and they've really done the best
nothing's been too much trouble they've
explained everything to him and I'm just
thankful to each and every one of them
she's desperate to get back to her two
young sons then whilst we're still with
her she's told she's leaving ICU that's
such good news we'll have to get you
there now because we're expecting more
people you've done extremely well though
haven't you you'll be fine on the world
so the Rings to co2 now to lead the way
okay well I didn't expect that it's all
stations go now
but still time to say thank you to the
people she believes kept her alive
the bond between Kara
and those who've come so close to death
is a shared one as is the sheer joy of
finally being able to say goodbye
Alex called that Star News in Warrington
hospital